the family of an eighteen-month girl who
died after falling 150 feet off a Royal
Caribbean cruise ship is suing the
cruise line today images included in the
lawsuit obtained by CBS News show where
Cloe Wiegand fell back in July
her grandfather Salmonella says he was
holding her against what he thought was
a closed window when she fell from his
grasp he faces a criminal charge in
Puerto Rico our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is in
South Bend Indiana where the family
lives David good morning so what are
they saying today well the law suits
gonna be filed this morning in Miami but
the attorney came here to South Bend
because the family lives here and has a
lot of support amongst members of the
community the lawsuit which we have read
will claim that Royal Caribbean cruise
line breached industry safety standards
by helped by having windows on board the
ship that can open without warning this
photo that was given to CBS News by the
family's attorney shows the window where
18 month old Chloe Wiegand fell from 150
feet to the ground below attorney
Michael Winckelmann says Chloe was in
the children's play area of the ship
when she wandered over to a nearby
window that's where her grandfather
Salmonella picked her up and sat her on
a wooden railing in front of the window
he insists he thought the window was
closed but it wasn't and Chloe fell
through his hands to the ground below he
spoke to us last month it was like it
was unbelievable it's like it
disappeared it's like the glass
disappeared attorney Winkelman who is
not representing the grandfather and his
criminal proceedings insists that the
windows on the cruise ship should have
had warnings on them if they were in an
open viewing area it's a hidden danger
that people can open them you're putting
those there in what should be like a
viewing section where you have this
railing it would encourage you to sit on
it to put a kid on it to do things on
that the lawsuit is expected to be filed
this morning in Miami it will show
examples of other cruise lines that the
family attorney argues have safety
screens or windows that cannot be opened
at all the family attorney will also
argue in the suit that the cruise line
should have known window guidelines as
newer boats owned by Royal Caribbean
either have windows that don't open or
employ safety devices
like window screens or guards the suit
will also claim the large gap between
the handrail and the window made it hard
for anello to distinguish the open
window from glass he told us why that
may have happened I am color blind so
that's been me that's something that you
are colorblind colorblind Eve I don't
know I just never saw it I've been told
that that's a reason that it might have
happened and there was a note from a
doctor that diagnosed him with being
colorblind we saw that note in the
lawsuit the family is gonna ask to be
compensated for pain and mental
suffering now you should know we have
tried for weeks to get Royal Caribbean
to tell us their side of the story to
correct any misinformation and they have
not
they've only said that this was a tragic
incident they've offered condolences and
just this morning a very short time ago
they told us that they haven't even seen
the lawsuit so they would have no
further comment grandfather Anthony is
too important Porto Rico next week he is
charged with negligent homicide that
story in New Zealand in the story now
with the family Royal Caribbean has a
lot going on but I will never be
convinced that that grandfather should
be charged it just seems to be
prolonging the entire tragedy everybody
agrees that it's a tragic accident
alright David thank you